- Dear Spike...
- Dear Oprah...
- Dear Stevie,
your music has guided me
through the most difficult moments
of my life.
- I get letters from so many
people that share their stories.
♪ I keep fighting voices
in my mind ♪
♪ That say I'm not enough ♪
- Wow! Are all of these letters
for me?
♪ Remind me once again... ♪
- Every time you make something,
you're throwing rocks in a pond.
You have no idea of the ripples
that are going to come back to you.
Every time you make something.
- All of us must
stand up together.
- If one person tells their story,
that allows other people to say...
- You know what? That happened to me.
That's me there.
- It's as though I'm watching my life
and the lives of my students on screen.
- I could speak to people about their
problems because I grew up struggling.
- You're fat, you're too brown.
Ballet was the first time I felt
like, "Wow, I'm beautiful."
- With you as an example,
I've become the first black woman
to get a Ph.D.
in aerospace engineering.
- I knew that I could
defy the odds, too.
- (whispering) Oh, my gosh.
- That can transform everything.
♪ You say I'm loved... ♪
- Big Bird, you showed me
how to accept people
for who they truly are,
starting with myself.
- Your music helped me create
the Equal Justice Initiative.
- That inspires me to want to write
more songs and play them better.
- You lit a fire inside of us,
and we're lighting that same fire
in other kids around the world.
- If every one of us focused on
something that you want to change,
we can change the world.
- Your legacy is every life
you've touched.
♪ Oh, I believe ♪
- Dear Spike...
- Dear Lin...
- Dear Stevie...
- Dear Oprah...
- Dear Gloria...
- Dear Big Bird...
- Dear Jane...
- Dear Aly...
- Dear Yara...
- Dear Misty...
- Your influence on me changed
the course of my life.
- Dear Gloria...
- Dear Jane...
- There's a line from "In The Heights"
that says wherever we go,
we rep our people.
Because of you,
wherever my life takes me,
I will always represent my people.
- Thank you...
Thank you.